the only way to actually drink this
garbage is to add all of these packets
and this vanilla thing and this vanilla
thing and this vanilla pen so we've been
dating almost four years we've been
dating for a year and a half I'm up and
about I like in 8:30 you know in 8:45
and then if I can't sleep in I'm going
til til I will wake up around 7:30 a.m.
go downstairs have a hearty breakfast
you know steel-cut oatmeal and I'll put
in like a banana and I'll just have like
a couple pop-tarts I brush my teeth
before I go in the shower that is
beeline efficient right because I'm
using the time the shower is warming up
I brush my teeth try to meditate for 15
or 20 minutes everyone talks about how I
need a meditate it's such a great thing
I think I've going long enough I can
admit this that I do blow-dry my hair
I'll give it a try we'll see maybe I'll
just be a new person tomorrow because I
let it an't place those crazy
expectations on it I feel awkward doing
my hair with a shirt on I always have to
like wide in the neck and then fit it
over my head so I don't mess my hair up
I'm being very specific here so you know
your routine okay
Steve also loves coffee and I absolutely
hate coffee
I also hate oatmeal and I hate pop-tarts
so I feel like I'm just gonna start off
the day in a really crappy mood you're
gonna feel great
I'm seized to being up at this hour that
I've just been lying here in this empty
bed okay I'm up this looks like a whole
lot of a yak probably not verse 20 first
cuz that's what he does I'm attempting
to meditate it's been two minutes and
I'm already so bored of myself could I'm
gonna turn on the shower brush my teeth
I'm almost hoping that I have some
leftover makeup residue somewhere on my
face or else I'll just look like a white
ghost I'm at 7-eleven right now passing
by the soda which is what I want this
coffee is definitely making me sweat I
don't even feel energized I just feel
like I am sweating so much and my
stomach hurts so thank you coffee
breaking your routine makes you really
upset
the reason I'm struggling this morning
is because I haven't add enough caffeine
and I'm used to drinking three coke
zeros by this point I don't know if you
don't brush your teeth for very long but
like the shower was warm like and I was
only halfway to my timer you brought up
teeth for too long I think if I had to
blow-dry my hair every single day it
would add an extra 10 to 15 minutes to
my routine because it just like take so
long takes me 30 seconds I love that
like my routine includes like oatmeal
and like meditation I sound like I'm
like in my 70s
the reason we're really doing this video
is because he wanted to come out as a 70
year old man